merci d'être avec nous Françoise Gatel
bonjour vous êtes sénatrice centriste
d'inet vilaine présidente de la
délégation sénatoriale collectivité
territoriale et à la décentralisation et
on va évidemment faire le bilan de ce
congrès des mers avec vous il s'est
achevé hier par un discours d'Elizabeth
borne auquel vous avez bien sûr assisté
je suis devant vous avec humilité et
détermination c'est ce qu'elle a dit au
maire de France vous avez été satisfaits
par la tonalité de ce discours je pense
que les mots
d'humilité voilà c'est juste parce que
je pense que cette femme en tout cas
elle pense qu'elle dit et elle fait pas
des vêtements donc vraiment moi je lui
dis mon respect c'était pas évident de
venir en congrès des mers c'est comme
chaque année
alors elle dit et je la crois quand elle
dit voilà on va dialoguer j'ai confiance
peut-être qu'on s'est mal pris bon ceci
dit on a beaucoup de faux départ depuis
quand même un long moment maintenant sur
un vrai départ pour vous dans les
relations entre mère et exécutif
Elisabeth borne monsieur bichu avec qui
on travaille sur le zéro
artificialisation on parle des
collectivités
des lieux le font donc je trouve que ça
c'est mieux qu'avant sans aucun même si
nous au niveau des collectivités je
trouve que dans le monde après c'est non
et que j'inclingo ça se passe bien
maintenant je pense que cet esprit il
n'a pas conquis suffisamment c'est à
dire je pense qu'il y a trop souvent
une domination berthienne c'est-à-dire
que Bercy
clos parfois le discours et la confiance
par la disparition de crédit donc il
faut que Madame borne elle convain Bercy
que la politique les finances aussi au
service de finalité et qu'il faut pas
qu'il décalage entre le discours ces
intentions qui sont vraies sincère et
puis ce qui se passe à la fin et
l'atterrissage et quand même on voit des
surprises persiennes si je puis dire on
va longuement parler de cette question
des finances puisque le Sénat évidemment
dans sa partie recette à voter pardon
des dispositifs de soutien collectivité
un mot sur la zéro artificielle c'était
c'est d'ailleurs une inquiétude des élus
c'était une attente d'un discours
d'Elisabeth borne elle a annoncé hier
une territorialisation elle dit je veux
pas réactiver le clivage urbain ruraux
c'était la bonne réponse pour vous alors
je je pense et je sais que le
gouvernement a compris que
ce truc de 0 artificialisation n'était
une folie c'est-à-dire il faut
réindustrialiser ramener des entreprises
il faut loger des habitants il faut
faire des infrastructures et on aura
zéro artificialisation et que ceux qui
se passait que le décret d'application
c'est que on éteignait la lumière dans
les campagnes puisque ils avaient le
noir à la moitié de ce qu'ils aient
consommé quand ils avaient voilà donc il
fallait réconcilier le Sénat c'est le
Sénat interpellé là dessus et le
gouvernement l'a compris nous nous
travaillons beaucoup et je pense qu'on
va se rejoindre et le groupe de travail
présidé par Valérie l'État et animée par
Jean-Baptiste blanc va rendre ses
conclusions dans pas longtemps et
j'espère qu'on va arriver au bout du
chemin l'idée étant il faut qu'on soit
économe dans la consommation de fonciers
mais on va pas éteindre la lumière
partout il faut que les gens continuent
à vivre et qui est des services donc sa
vraie développement durable qu'on veut
faire on va parler des finances
évidemment préoccupation majeure des
élus endurants second congrès vous
examinez cette semaine le budget la
partie recette a été votée hier et
plusieurs modifications ont été
apportées pour soutenir les
collectivités on voit ça avec Quentin
Calmet
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour Oriane bonjour François
Locatel je suis un peu pris le rideau
tout va bien je suis là
c'est surtout le dossier des
collectivités locales sur le dossier des
collectivités
voilà on va commencer par évoquer la
CVAE bien sûr puisque ça fait plusieurs
semaines qu'on en parle rien notamment
sur cette antenne que les élus alertes
sur cette suppression on parle de cette
impôt payé par les entreprises et
perçues par les départements et les
intercommunalités un des derniers
leviers de fiscalité des collectivités
locales depuis la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation donc le gouvernement
voulait dans ce budget supprimé la CVAE
la droite sénatoriale voulait plutôt
reporter la suppression le temps de
mieux travailler sur la compensation de
cette CVAE et coup de théâtre en séance
c'était lundi vers midi une majorité a
voté à main levée pour supprimer la
suppression en clair pour maintenir la
CVAE écouter un sénateur écologiste
c'était donc lundi en séance
on peut pas parler de la suppression de
la CVAE sans parler des services que
rendent les collectivités monsieur le
ministre je vous l'ai dit à plusieurs
reprises vous soutenez avec une grande
vigueur les entreprises mais soutenez
les collectivités territoriales vous
savez très bien que le rôle est aussi
fondamental pour notre pays et je me
permets de le dire aussi d'accord la
richesse se crée dans les entreprises
mais la cohésion sociale se crée par les
collectivités le rayonnement culturel de
notre pays se crée par les collectivités
la qualité de vie se crée par nos
collectivités et c'est aussi pour ça que
des entreprises s'installent chez nous
voilà plaidoyer en faveur des
collectivités locales arrêtons-nous un
instant sur cette cbae si vous voulez
bien Françoise Gatel on en avait parlé
déjà depuis le Congrès des départements
qui se tenaient à Agen c'était qu'il y a
un mois ça inquiétait beaucoup les
départements que dire de cette
suppression de la suppression en séance
vous êtes d'accord ou vous auriez
préféré un retard vous comment est-ce
que vous voyez que la séquence je pense
que dire qu'on supprime
la proposition du gouvernement c'est
vraiment un signe un symbole c'est dans
ce pays je pense que il faut qu'on soit
conscient que les impôts servent à
l'action publique et que le lien entre
les collectivités et les entreprises
c'est important en Bretagne aujourd'hui
près de chez moi il y a une usine qui
doit ouvrir avec 500 emplois on a
aujourd'hui des militants qui veulent
pas de cette usine les maires et les
élus défendent ce projet mais si vous
n'avez pas l'argument de ressources
venant
de l'entreprise pour expliquer que cette
entreprise c'est bien ça fait du
développement ça va aider à financer des
équipements publics vous n'avez plus
aucun argument pour accueillir des
entreprises la pollution la nuisance
d'une entreprise est mieux acceptée si
on sait qu'on perçoit des impôts sur
cette entreprise que l'entreprise
contribue par ses ressources à la
vitalité du territoire alors la
suppression de la c.e c'est comme la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
c'est VAE c'est intelligent
économiquement de supprimer
parce que ça rend nos entreprises plus
performantes ok sauf qu'à un moment la
deuxième partie de l'équation c'est à
quoi sert cet argent et comment on fait
donc on a décidé de supprimer mais on
n'a pas vraiment examiné la sécurité du
remplacement donc nous on demandait un
peu de temps pour être sûr de
l'atterrissage et pas à faire encore des
aventures financières
ils demandaient un report d'un an
pourquoi vous n'avez pas absolument ah
bah parce qu'on est allé plus fort et
plus loin c'est comme ça ça vous avez vu
comment ça s'est passé oh mais on va on
va voir comment on va voir
l'atterrissage l'atterrissage final sur
ce qu'a dit Elisabeth bornière juste un
mot Quentin là-dessus puisque Elizabeth
borne elle a parlé de la CV elle a dit
que ça serait compensée par de la TVA
qui est plus dynamique que du coup ça
sera bénéfique pour les collectivités
mais que ça sera calculé sur les
dernières années connues 2020-2023 ça
c'est bien ça ou pas alors je pense que
la TVA est un impôt dynamique donc c'est
pas pas forcément une mauvaise idée
maintenant il faut quand même qu'on
regarde bien le montant de l'addition si
Jupiler et comme nous on a supprimé la
la suppression c'est parce que je
rappelle qu'à un moment il y a quand
même eu un amendement au Sénat pour dire
que d'ores et déjà on supprime la moitié
de la CVAE
et que nous ça n'était pas possible la
position du Sénat c'est-à-dire on
regarde ce qui va se passer et après on
y va
comment est-ce qu'on explique que la
droite soit pas et pas eu gain de cause
puisqu'on le dit la droite voulait aller
attendre un peu avant la suppression de
la CVAE finalement il y a une majorité
de circonstances la droite a été un peu
battue vous reconnaissez
je sais pas ce que vous appelez la
droite
le groupe LR oui c'est-à-dire qu'à un
moment
chacun a dit qu'il y avait une autre
façon de prendre les choses et que
c'était et que sans doute c'était mieux
d'aller dans ce sens là que de choisir
une suppression à hauteur 50% on
continue quand un petit évidemment il y
a eu d'autres mesures avec le volet du
budget consacré collectivité les
sénateurs adopté d'autres mesures
importantes oui on pense par exemple à
l'augmentation de la DGF la dotation
globale de fonctionnement le nerf de la
guerre pour que les budgets quand on est
une collectivité donc les sénateurs ont
voté une augmentation de la DGF au même
niveau que l'inflation autre mesure
voter cette semaine qui concerne les
collectivités local l'élargissement du
filet de sécurité énergétique à toutes
les communes et pas simplement au quart
des communes qui sont le plus en
difficulté alors commençons par la DGF
le gouvernement voulait augmenter de 320
millions d'euros les sénateurs ont
préféré donc la coller à l'inflation qui
est donc de 4 et demi pour cent l'année
prochaine c'est le chiffre qui est ici
quant au filet de sécurité les sénateurs
ont élargiettes les communes et on le
voit effectivement c'est le point qui
est là on le voit c'est aussi le Congrès
des mères qui pèse sur toutes ces
modifications les sénateurs qui vont
encore plus loin que que ce que vous
voulez le rapporteur non nous on n'a pas
eu on n'a pas voulu avoir un effet
congrès des mers ces pensées cette
affaire la l'indexation de la dotation
sur l'inflation moi j'ai présenté un
amendement de cette nature et je le
défends depuis longtemps pourquoi c'est
parce que je pense que ce qu'il faut et
pour le gouvernement et pour nous et
pour les entreprises c'est que ce soit
simple
et sur parce que quand les collectivités
demandent une indexation sur l'inflation
c'est parce que leurs dépenses de
cantine de transport et d'assainissement
augmentent avec ça et que si les
collectivités elles n'ont pas une
sécurité ça veut dire que demain ne vont
pas investir et investir ça veut dire
quoi c'est faire travailler les
entreprises soutenir l'emploi donc quand
on demande ça c'est pas un cadeau qu'on
fait à une offre de charité qui serait
collectivité vu qu'on arrête de
raisonner comme ça c'est parce que nous
on a besoin d'assurer ce qu'on appelle
les services essentiels et demain il
faut que les collectivités puissent
continuer de le moteur de l'économie
s'il n'y a pas d'investissement des
entreprises il y a de des collectivités
il n'y a pas de carnet de commandes pour
les entreprises et en plus le
gouvernement est en train de s'embêter
sincèrement avec son filet de sécurité
alors c'est tellement compliqué qu'on a
passé deux heures l'autre soir essayer
de dire le niveau d'endettement c'est
une usine à gaz qui qui en fait ne va
pas vraiment moi je crois profiter ou
être utilisable par des toutes les
collectivités donc on va pas dépenser
l'argent on va on va voir
Elisabeth borne elle a reconnu quand
même que c'était une usine à Gana elle a
dit que c'était trop complexe pour les
collectifs mais oui et j'ai entendu à la
conférence de presse ou à la
présentation qu'elle avait fait de ça
qu'elle m'avait dit que c'était tout vu
c'est à dire là-dessus il va y avoir de
planification nous on a proposé au Sénat
un truc alors très simple très sûr et
raisonnable c'est un filet de sécurité
c'est-à-dire un amortissement en quelque
sorte du prix de la hausse du prix de de
l'énergie pour toutes les collectivités
donc c'est simple tout le monde y a
accès parce que les collectivités font
toutes des services essentiels sur la
DGF non mais allez on voit toutes ces
modifications là qu'on est sur les
collectivités locales est-ce que ce ne
sont pas autant de ligne rouge avec le
gouvernement qui font que le texte du
Sénat va être inacceptable pour pour le
gouvernement c'est le gouvernement qui
dit que c'est rouge
mais en même temps on a proposé des
recettes je veux dire le groupe
centriste il a proposé comme il l'a déjà
fait en 2022 une contribution solidaire
exceptionnelle des super profits
peut-être mais il appartient au
gouvernement de réfléchir on n'arrête
pas de nous causer je pense que au Sénat
d'après ce qu'a dit hier Elizabeth borne
dans son discours elle a pas l'air de
vous suivre vous pensez que ça va être
en tout cas elle nous a pas précédé sur
l'idée ça c'est sûr
elle a rappelé hier dans son discours
que c'est une augmentation inédite que
95% des collectivités allez voir leur
dotation se stabiliser ou augmenter moi
je veux bien tout ça mais en fait je
pense que ce que nous proposons avec
cette indexation c'est beaucoup plus
simple et au final je ne suis pas sûr
que ça coûterait plus cher au
gouvernement même si on vous avez une
dotation de fonctionnement qu'augmenter
d'un milliard et c'est pas le cas que ce
qu'on a proposé la hausse du coût de
l'énergie c'est 11 milliards
pour finir là-dessus le gouvernement
utilise de 49-3 à l'Assemblée nationale
vous pensez que il va chercher à faire
quoi sur le budget et c'est de trouver
un compromis avec les sénateurs ou
réécrire le texte complètement d'un
trade plume avec le 49-3 ah bah moi
enfin personne ne comprendrais ça je
veux dire on était tous hier
soir il peut pas y avoir la parole du
Congrès de Versailles et derrière un
49-3 qu'il fasse tout ce qu'on a fait
donc jusqu'où le gouvernement va
accepter d'avancer j'en sais mais
vraiment moi
l'Assemblée sur ce budget j'en perdrai
mon latin
un mot quand même sur les contrats de
cas puisque ça aussi c'était une des
élus elle a été claire elle a dit il y
aura pas de nouveau contrat de Cahors il
y aura pas de coercition et on va
réfléchir avec les parlementaires à une
trajectoire similaire pour l'État et les
collectivités ça vous satisfait ça oui
c'est ce que demandait Gérard lâcher
puis je suis très juste rappeler quand
même que toutes les collectivités ont un
budget équilibré parce que vous ne
pouvez pas emprunter pour payer vos
fonctionnaires payer payer la cantine ça
c'est pas possible donc il faut pas
qu'on nous donne de leçons et que l'on
dise on n'est pas plus exigeant avec les
collectivités que l'on est avec l'État
moi ça me semble mais il faut quand même
rappeler que il y a un principe de libre
administration
on n'est pas les seuls
oui on va pas être puni parce que à un
moment
on aurait mal géré ce qui est pas le cas
alors il y a toujours un ou deux
exemples mais quand la cantine augmente
quand l'énergie développement de vous
dépensez plus enfin je veux dire voilà
donc moi j'espère que la première nuit
et je doute pas que ça sincérité mais il
faut qu'elle aille contaminer Bercy quoi
parce que c'est non non mais s'ils sont
sans plaisanter on a un vrai sujet là
c'est à dire à Bercy il ne nous
comprennent pas ils ont un langage de
comptable et ils comprennent pas la
vraie vie un mot content pour être un
pour être complet puisque le Sénat on
l'a dit à voter la partie recette avec
d'autres modifications du budget
un petit récap puisque ça fait
maintenant une semaine huit jours que
les sénateurs se sont emparés du projet
loi de finance on va voir tout ce qui a
été adopté ou pas depuis la semaine
dernière puisque on a retenu par exemple
qu'il n'y avait pas eu de majorité pour
voter une taxation des super profits
au-delà de ce que prévoit la Commission
européenne on le voit c'est le premier
point autre mesure la baisse de la TVA
sur les transports collectifs de 10% à
5,5 les sénateurs vous avez également
adopté un tarif réduit des carburants
pour les aides à domicile en milieu
rural
a retenu aussi avec une majorité avait
rejeté le projet de création d'un d'un
loto de la biodiversité pourtant dans
les cartons à Bercy même question pour
la CVAE et que pour les mesures sur les
collectivités locales qu'est-ce qui va
rester de toutes ces autres
modifications qui ont déjà eu lieu
depuis le début alors il y en a deux qui
sont importants c'est la baisse de la
TVA dans les transports en commun
aujourd'hui à l'exception du TGV qui
sont ouverts à la concurrence mais pour
tous les autres c'est important et puis
moi je suis très content de la mesure
pour les aides à domicile en milieu
rural parce que
sont souvent des femmes qui ont des
horaires difficiles qui vont travailler
chez les personnes âgées qui font
beaucoup de kilomètres dans des dans des
territoires où il y a pas de bus et un
métier pour lequel on a du mal à
recruter et donc ça c'est vraiment une
mesure
sociale très intelligente parce que
c'est aussi accompagner le
vieillissement de personnes parfois
isolées donc j'espère que cette mesure
c'est une mesure va être conservée merci
Quentin à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure on on va parler des cabinets de
conseils la ferme McKinsey qui revient
devant de l'actu une question pour
Françoise gatté on l'a fait maintenant
on repart des collectivités
effectivement vous avez vu cette
communication du parquet national
financier qui a annoncé hier il y a un
communiqué qu'il y avait bien trois
enquêtes qui étaient en cours dont une
qui concerne les élections
présidentielles de 2017 et 2022 c'est
peut-être le volet le plus surprenant
puisque voilà les affaires
d'optimisation fiscale de McKinsey on
savait qu'il y avait une enquête le fait
qu'on enquête sur les deux campagnes
présidentielles de 2016 2022 c'est
c'était surprenant comment est-ce que
vous avez réagi ah bah moi j'ai appris
j'ai appris comme tout le monde les
choses ensuite la justice dans notre
pays elle est totalement indépendante
elle entreprend des choses et que moi je
trouve que ça montre bien qu'on est dans
une démocratie voilà il appartient à la
justice de faire son travail et et on
verra donc ça il me beaucoup moi je dis
aussi
attendons aussi les les résultats le sén
au coeur de la faire puisque c'est le
rapport sénatorial de mars qui a
enclenché une partie de l'affaire vous
le reconnaissez alors au coeur de
l'affaire je sais pas de café à vous
parler en attendant de faire le Sénat a
beaucoup travaillé voilà avec notamment
notre collègue Bazin est assis ils ont
fait un travail remarquable sur le
recours au cabinet privé effectivement
le rapport a été voté à l'unanimité il y
a plus de clarté de transparence c'est
parfait merci Quentin on en reparle
évidemment tout à l'heure on va aller à
Rennes du côté de chez vous on retrouve
Stéphane Besnier que vous connaissez
bien directeur de l'information de TVN
bonjour Stéphane merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous on revient à la question des
collectivités puisque retour avec vous
sur l'un des motifs d'inquiétude des
élus locaux
oui bah si ça n'est pas une surprise les
élus les collectivités sont
particulièrement inquiets principalement
de cette hausse de l'énergie on entend
parler dans les collectivités de X4 x 5
pour cette année 2023 donc les motifs
d'inquiétude sont bien les biens
présents alors on entend certaines
choses dans certaines communes ce sera
fromage ou dessert on va réduire
peut-être la taille des assiettes pour
mettre un peu moins car on ne veut pas
se faire supporter ce prix et des
augmentations aux familles et puis on
entend aussi que les piscines pourraient
baisser de 1 ou 2 degrés pour ne pas
alourdir les factures en tout cas
sénatrice Françoise Gatel il y a des
motifs d'inquiétude parce que le fil
rouge de ce congrès des mers et des
présidents d'intercaux c'était sur le
pouvoir d'agir en étant en mesure de se
poser cette question est-ce que l'on
pourra encore agir au quotidien avec
efficacité auprès des populations mais
j'ai une question plus sur le rôle entre
les communes et les intercommunalités
comment aujourd'hui mieux faire
travailler cette coopération pour faire
ensemble ce qu'il est difficile parfois
de faire seul bonjour Stéphane excellent
résumé de ce qui est l'intercommunalité
en Bretagne on est depuis longtemps
convaincu de l'importance de
l'intercommunalité ça se passe bien
aujourd'hui chacun sait que les communes
sont très importantes le maire c'est
l'interlocuteur et le cœur de l'affaire
parce que c'est lui qui incarne
physiquement les choses mais à un moment
pour accueillir des entreprises pour
faire des structures pour la petite
enfance faire des équipements sportifs
c'est plus intelligent de travailler
ensemble au sein d'une interco ce qui
fait qu'on a plus en dépensant moins
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui
l'intercommunalité va permettre avec les
communes membres de gérer au mieux une
période qu'une période difficile vous
l'avez évoqué et en même temps moi je le
dis très franchement je suis vraiment
une apôtre de l'intercommunalité mais
l'intercommunalité n'est pas une tutelle
de la commune c'est un espace de
coopération elle a pas décidé en lieu et
place on doit respecter ce cœur de la
démocratie et celui qui au final le
président l'archidu tout le temps il a
apporté dans gueulades il est
responsable de tout c'est le maire parce
que au-delà de l'efficacité c'est-à-dire
de ce que vous avez ok le prix de la
cantine le prix de la piscine un moment
vous avez besoin d'avoir une personne
que vous allez interpeller parce que
vous avez besoin de sentir que la
République elle est partout et elle est
pour tous donc le maire c'est vraiment
la personne centrale et puis après
l'interco comme les syndicats sont des
outils formidables très intelligents que
les communes
des intercos ne doit pas se faire et des
métropoles ne doit pas se faire au
détriment des communes
et parfois Stéphane baigner il le sait
en Ille-et-Vilaine on a parfois
l'impression que les intercommunalités
dominent et que les interlocuteurs de
l'État au lieu de parler à 35000 mères
ils vont parler à quelques milliers
d'intercos ça va plus vite
ils pensent que ça va plus loin c'est
faux c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui ce sont
bien les mers qui sont élus par leur
concitoyens et qui doivent rendre des
comptes et celui qui rend des comptes
celui qui est tenu comme responsable
c'est lui qui doit participer à des
décisions par contre ta mère il peut
plus être tout seul mais en Bretagne en
Ille-et-Vilaine cher Stéphane vous savez
bien que voilà nous on est dans cette
démarche très positive et en même temps
on reste toujours vigilant et exigeant
pour que l'intercom ne marche pas sur
les pieds de la commune ce qui ferait
qu'on se prendra les pieds dans le tapis
je pense merci Stéphane Besnier merci
beaucoup avec nos directeurs de
l'information de TV Rennes un dernier
mot sur ce vote hier à l'Assemblée
Françoise Gatel puisque les députés ont
voté très largement l'une des
propositions des insoumis inscrire le
droit à l'IVG dans la Constitution le
Sénat vers voter avait refusé par nom de
voter un taxe similaire qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de ce vote moi je suis
contente que vous me posez la question
puisqu'on a beaucoup de mal à s'exprimer
je rappelle que cette proposition de loi
ne vient pas dire que le droit à l'IVG
serait remis en cause dans notre pays il
ne l'est pas aujourd'hui on a une
proposition qui est devenue une
proposition de loi adoptée qui nous fait
croire que sans cette proposition de loi
et sans cette intégration dans la
Constitution le droit à l'iviger serait
contesté c'est faux moi je n'ai pas voté
au Sénat cette constitutionnalisation
parce que je pense que je pense deux
choses d'abord c'est pas parce que vous
mettez dans la Constitution que vous ne
pouvez pas modifier et qu'aujourd'hui le
sujet c'est comment on permet à des
femmes d'avoir recours à ce droit à
l'iviger comment on a un accueil dans
les hôpitaux comment on a des médecins
qui pratiquent ces actes-là comment on
agit mieux en prévention et mettre ça
dans la Constitution sincèrement vous
voyez c'est comme un symbole mais le
symbole ne fait pas le symbole ne fait
pas les choses donc moi je je et
deuxième élément vous savez quand
j'entends les arguments on me dit
le droit à l'IVG est en danger parce que
à l'extérieur il y a des mouvements de
contestation et de radissements de la
loi moi ça me fait un peu peur parce que
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est comme
si on avait acté le fait qu'en 2027 on
aurait une élection présidentielle qui
nuirait profondément la démocratie et
moi je pense qu'il faut résister il faut
se battre pour et en plus même le
fromage à voter pour la
constitutionnalisation un dernier mot
rapidement pour être clair puisque
l'aval du Sénat est indispensable pour
la poursuite de ce texte vous
continuerez à voter contre non mais moi
je ne voterai pas pour une mesure qui
aujourd'hui est un leurre pour la
population merci Françoise Gatel merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité et
d'être venu faire le bilan de ce congrès
des mères avec nous on continuera
évidemment à en parler dans 20 minutes
dans le club des territoires puisque
Elizabeth borne a fait plusieurs
annonces les mers ont-ils été convaincu
on les entendra dans 20 minutes d'abord
on va parler du crâne avec notre invité
suivant c'est Jean-François Colosimo qui
nous rejoint